let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
we start here all right number one
the perceptive among us you know uh
really from the beginning
knew that the me too movement was a
fraud it was
ideological it was anti-male while
masquerading as
an ethical movement which it never was
now if you need
more evidence of this even after all
these years then i would point you to
katie hill disgraced former
congresswoman
who had a special announcement yesterday
she says
i can finally announce another exciting
project i'm so honored to be played by
the
the iconic elizabeth moss and thrilled
to work with this incredible team guess
i'm about to add movie producer to my
resume and there's a link to an article
about this uh this movie it's a movie
about katie hill
lionizing katie hill with feminist
favorite elizabeth moss
in the lead i think she's the one she
does handmaid's tale
right isn't she in that i have no idea
but that's that's why that's probably
why the feminists like her
meanwhile um katie hill resigned from
congress if you recall following a
scandal in which it was revealed that
she was
sexually taking advantage of her staff
members
she had involved one of them in a
threesome with her then husband
and there were other major ethical
problems as well remember
we have been told by me too
that power dynamics make it so that even
consensual relationships
often times are not really consensual
okay yes doesn't always mean yes this is
what we've been told
the power dynamics between a congress
member and a staffer
make it so that consent is not fully
possible
this isn't my argument okay this isn't
what i'm saying
it this is the metoo argument this is
what they say
and according to that argument katie
hill is a predator according to them
if they were to apply their logic
consistently which of course they don't
now you don't have to take it from me
though an apparent former staff member
uh commandeered hill's congressional
twitter account which has just been
sitting there you know after she left
uh or resided disgrace she had her
twitter account which doesn't have
access to anymore
and this morning there were some tweets
coming out
on that account blasting the movie
saying that hill took advantage of her
subordinates caused them harm you know
this is what the two would say
hill now claims that the account was
hacked but there's no reason to think it
was hacked
her staff would have had access to that
account and it looks like they're using
it or at least
one of them is using it to say hey you
know she was a pretty horrible boss and
she took advantage of her staff
maybe don't make a movie about her where
she's the hero
but hill gets her own rules you know she
doesn't have to play by the same rules
as everybody else
um you want to talk about privilege here
it is
she's the protagonist in a film about
her own sex scandal you think any
disgraced republican politician would
ever get that treatment
exact same circumstances okay would that
ever happen no
of course not number two now um it's
long been
my contention that bill de blasio
is of new york is is not only the worst
mayor in history but also possibly
the cringiest dork in history too i
think he might he might get that title
as well
if you don't believe me then uh watch
this
[Music]
yes that was uh de blasio heroically
in slow motion with the music playing
putting a mask on his face
they took a video of that puts the mask
on then offers an awkward
salute as well i don't know who the
salute is to but he does and then he
walks back and it's like
look wear the damn mask if you want okay
but stop trying to make it into a heroic
manly act on your part
biden is doing the same thing here's a
video from the biden campaign yesterday
uh so so you see him there supposed to
be con contrasting
him with with trump and you see him
putting on the mask like a champ while
trump takes his off
how heroic this is what it takes to be a
hero now
just put a mask on it's that easy
which is great uh i mean i i guess i
should be i'm a hero too
every time i you know walk into a
grocery store and i have to put the mask
on cause i'm forced to
actually it's a heroic act i'm a hero
all right
number three um meanwhile speaking of
dumb theatrics
with the vp debate coming up uh there's
been this back and forth between
the camps biden trump camp over putting
a plexiglas
divider between the candidates on stage
now pence initially balked at this idea
but has now
agreed has relented and you can see them
putting up the the divider there
what does this achieve they're 12 feet
apart
they both they both tested negative
for the virus what does the glass
divider achieve
well nothing i mean if one of them
could manage to infect the other despite
being negative
and asymptomatic and being 12 feet apart
if they could somehow pull off that
trick then the glass barrier probably
won't do much anyway
so there doesn't seem to be a lot of
much of a point here at least medically
or scientifically
um but of course we know that that
the real reason it's there is for two
reasons number one
the biting campaign wants it there
because it gives the impression
that pence is sick and weak and infected
it's bad optics for him so that's what
that's all this is about
it's just to remind the public as
they're watching the debate oh yeah
that's the sick guy over there
even though he's not and that's what
this is really about but also number two
it's it's part of the coveted theater
that we've seen all across the country
for months where measures are taken
things are done often with no apparent
scientific justification or reason with
no ration
no rationale behind them really but the
idea
is that at least if we're doing
something it's better than nothing
even if the something is totally
arbitrary and ineffectual
and we've been in that kind of culture
for a long time it's not just with coven
we've been in this culture where you
know there's there's a there's a bad
thing that happens or there's something
we have to deal with
and the cry comes out from the public
saying do something just
somebody do something i don't care just
anything
um you get this anytime there's a uh you
know
mass shooting and you have many
americans who say to the government the
federal government just just just do
something just anything just do
something
and they go and they pass a law is the
law going to help
is it going to actually achieve anything
does it get to the core of the problem
no but it's something and so we should
be satisfied with that
getting a lot with that with a lot of
that with covet as well and it's
ridiculous and not actually helpful okay
number two
so this is a story that i've largely
ignored and
for uh for good reason i think that's
the story of
claudia conway the daughter of kellyanne
conway and george conway
she's been on social media mostly on
tick tock it seems embarrassing her
mother
spilling secrets things she thinks she
claims our secrets anyway this is a 15
year old girl we're talking about here
um and you know sometimes recording her
mother without permission and posting it
online
again the girl is 15 years old and the
leftist media they love it
as you'd expect because they have the
ethical sensibility of a tarantula so
for them this is great they see no
problem with it
in fact you can see in the headlines um
a few headlines here we're told that the
15 year old claudia conway is the
whistleblower of our time
now the way they're taking advantage of
this girl is obviously sick and
the sexual undertones of some of this
stuff from the left is even sicker
i mean look at this from neil brennan
who's a comedian apparently on netflix
no surprise there
and he says that claudia should make an
only fan's account
for white house intel only fans
talking about a 15 year old so that's
all disturbing and gross but
i keep going back when i see these
stories
you know i keep going back personally um
to the question of why
this girl has a phone with the internet
in the first place
if this were my daughter and i
understand the family dynamics here are
in far be it for me to dispense
parenting advice okay but and the family
dynamics are very strange
at least from the outside i mean there's
in there there are complicated family
dynamics of any family
right but uh still i i mean if this were
my daughter i would
i would i would take her phone which i
am paying for
i paid for the phone i'm paying for the
the service i'm paying for everything
so it's my price it's my property it's
not hers
and i would take my property
and uh i would bring it out into the
into the uh
garage and i would grab a hammer and i
would smash it with a hammer and then i
would throw the pieces in a garbage can
that's what i would do
so i'm not sure why she's allowed to
continue having a phone
but then again look this is coming from
from me and
i'm someone who i can't really see any
reason why
any 15 year old person should have
a phone with the internet on it
there's really nothing good that can
come of it period
there is there is no net positive to
your child even at the age of 15 having
a phone with the internet
nothing good so all you can hope
is that the damage it does which you
know it will do
won't be that bad so at that point it's
all about damage
you give them the phone which you have
paid for and
you've purchased it with your own money
and you hand it to them
this thing that you know is going to do
damage and now all you're doing is
damage control
what about just not giving them the
phone
if your kid gets to an age or they
actually have a job and they can go out
and buy
the phone themselves you know maybe
that's a good cutoff age for when they
can have if
you can buy it with your money even then
i mean if they're living in under your
house it's your rules and if you tell
them they can't have even if it's their
money it's it's still your house you can
have the rules you want but
i could see an argument there if it's
their if it's if it's
their money and they're earning and
that's what they want to spend it on
then there could be a good lesson there
but
when it's not even their money and
you're paying for it and buying it going
out of your way spending
all this money on these expensive
gadgets that you know will hurt them
uh i just i don't see it i don't know i
i don't see the parenting strategy i
really don't
number five um finally
they got him folks this is it they
finally got him
they have proven that donald trump is
actually
as suspected literally hitler literally
okay matt denzeko um a self-described
journalist and filmmaker
he has uh on twitter taken the video
that trump released of of him returning
from the hospital
and he's juxtaposed it next to the
triumph of the will which is a nazi
propaganda film from the 30s
and what he found is stunning okay just
watch this you can see it here
and if you're listening to the audio
podcast what we're seeing here is is it
is it matches up exactly
the two videos match up exactly shot for
shot
you can see it right down the line
stunning apparently the trump campaign
decided to do a shot-for-shot remake of
a nazi propaganda film
because why not well i can think of many
reasons why not
actually and i can't think of any
reasons to do that
even if you are secret nazis
why would you do that the whole point of
being a secret nazi is that you don't
let people know
so that doesn't make a lot of sense
although it starts to make sense it
becomes less confusing when you realize
that oh no wait
they didn't do that at all this is total
nonsense it has over
20 000 retweets on twitter of course but
it's total absolute nonsense what uh dan
ziko actually did
is he took a two-hour nazi film
and he searched for shots that resembled
the trump video
and all the trump video the trump video
is just simply helicopter lands
trump walks out and then he's on a
balcony that's it that's all the video
is
now if the video lined up that perfectly
like if if the triumph of the will was
also just a two-minute video and it and
the shots lined up that perfectly
then even i would admit well it's
probably you know that's probably still
a coincidence but it's a hell of a
coincidence
except in this case no they took a
two-hour movie or this guy took a
two-hour movie
and searched through cherry-picking the
same sorts of shots and then just
line them up edit it stitched it
together to make
he basically he made his own nazi
propaganda film this isn't
that what you just saw there that's not
trying for the world that's that's matt
danziko's nazi propaganda film that he
created
after the fact he he created it based on
the trump video
and then said wow these things really
line up who would have thought
how did that happen well i know how it
happened i did it myself
now the problem of course is that you
could do that with any political ad okay
you could take any political ad probably
and
you could find in it probably a few
shots at least that resemble
some nazi propaganda oh look they're
both waving go to balcony
you know what else you know what else
you could do you could search through
mineconf
i bet to find the same words you could
find
i bet you there are words in mineconf
um that are also in other books in fact
i have i have my my copy of minecomp
right here
and um you know i could you know i could
even just looking through it like for
example
i the word of the word
the both in mine comp
my god think about this
of and the the and of
where do those words sound familiar
the art of the deal the trump book
wow the trump book is essentially
minecomp
incredible um anyway by the way this is
not really minecon
just so you know media matters uh this
is not really minecomp this is bill
bryson a short
history of nearly everything i don't
mean to impugn bill bryson in this way
this is actually a great book and it's
got nothing to do just to clarify it's
got nothing to do with nazi
nazis or hitler or anything like that
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content